la cgt finira-t-elle par avoir la peau
de la loi travail
j'aurais cependant enchère de forme de
votre question parce que avoir la peau
est ce qu'on est aujourd'hui dans le
gouvernement uniquement nubile et par
l'idée d'avoir la peau de quelqu'un ou
de sauver sa propre peau quand on est en
responsabilité au gouvernement de voir
cette faire en sorte que les conditions
économiques les conditions budgétaires
les conditions sociales permettent au
pays de progresser
il s'agit pas d'avoir la peau de l'un la
peau de l'autre
je crois que j'ai besoin pour vos à
l'ambition qu'elle venait de rappeler
ray une forme d'apaisement dans le débat
le débat et a eu lieu l'été vif
il a même vu un peu à l'assemblée jean
torrent j'entends dire que le 49-3 cours
est interrompue
empêcher toute forme de débat ira
travaux en commissions et début de
travaux dans l'hémicycle puisse être
reprendre ils vont entreprendre au sénat
que suite à l'assemblée et des
discussions il ya eu des amodiations de
la loi des aménagements de la loi
certains disent qu'on a vidé la loi de
sa substance d'autres disent mais non ça
reste une loi extrêmement pénalisante
j'allais dire c'est peut-être aussi le
signe qu'on est dans une espèce de
liquide mais leur l'apaisement
l'apaisement vous appeler à l'apaisement
que peut faire le gouvernement ou des je
pense d'abord que il faut que les
organisations syndicales tellement la
cgt mais pas que la cgt et prennent
leurs responsabilités la responsabilité
c'est qu'au moment au moment où la
croissance s'améliorent ce que confirme
aujourd'hui le fmi le fmi vient vient
effectivement de relever sa prévision de
croissance
il était à 1 1 nous nous avons posé
comme hypothèse 1.5 pour deux externes
alors aujourd'hui le fait me dit oui on
aura une croissance en france le prêt de
l'impression elle dit qu'elle prend ses
responsabilités en bloquant mais je
justement que je pense qu'au moment où
la croissance reprend de façon plutôt
significative pour espérer mieux
c'est un mauvais coup qui peut être
porté à l'économie des journées grève
des journées de frilosité dans le monde
du travail dans les déplacements
c'est traditionnel ça ne l'est déjà un
mauvais goût
oui donc il est temps d'en sortir et
vous l'avez déjà chiffré ce mauvais coup
pour l'économie en or au nom et pour
l'instant il est bien sûr trop tôt pour
en parler mais vous savez que tous les
ai tous les événements qui se passent en
france aussi un retentissement sur
l'attractivité de notre pays que ce soit
en matière économique soit en matière
touristique et je pense qu'il est temps
maintenant d'en sortir mais c'est pas du
tout la voie qu'emprunte la cgt vous
avez vu la multiplication des blocages
l'appelle maintenant on aime à la grève
reconductible à la sncf à la fin du mois
oui une forme un peu de de dispersion en
lançant un mouvement reconductible à la
sncf on annonce une grève à la ratp
on a ces blocages dans les raffineries
dans les dépôts de carburant je crois
qu'il a une attitude que les français de
leurs commence un petit peu à hama le
recevoir vous attendez une condamnation
des français ceux qui se lèvent le matin
concours et qui parie sur l'avenir pour
reprendre l'expression d' emmanuel
macron nous évitons les mots qui
blessent les mots qui vexe familles sont
prises en otage je n'aime pas ce
vocabulaire
je n'aime pas ce qu'est valeur il s'agit
que chacun dans une situation qui est
difficile d'être sûr économique et
social qui est tendu vous l'avez dit il
s'agit un moment donné de dire que tu es
me remets ton ce pays en marche c'est ce
que nous faisons un responsabilité ou en
posant sa nombre de principes dans la
loi qui peuvent changer l'état d'esprit
qui peuvent parfois interpellés ont
souvent été mal présentée d'ailleurs
souvent caricaturée je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont en train
d'en prendre conscience que vous aviez
en phase de vente plutôt que moi
philippe martinez le leader de la cgt
que lui diriez vous je le dirai que il
ya eu des évolutions que il a
probablement lui un peu trop vite les
propositions qui sont contenues dans le
projet de loi et qu'il est temps
maintenant de sortir par le haut de
cette difficulté parce que sinon il ya
un risque économique effectivement d'un
quand l'économie va mal c'est finalement
un risque social qui se concrétise et
des difficultés souvent pour les gens du
plu monnaie il ya des blocages qui
pénalise l'économie ou où la vie des
gens mais il ya aussi des formes de
violence qu'ils sont
décidément contente de rupture si on
élargit entre la cgt aujourd'hui du
pacte entre la cgt et le pays pas sûr
que la cgt signe un pacte avec le pays
c'est par une signature patras et la cgt
n'est quand même pas le seul la seule
organisation syndicale de ce pays à son
nombre d'organisations syndicales qui se
sont inscrits dans des démarches
différentes de ceux de la cgt
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle
baisse d'impôts en 2017 après celle de
2015 2016 alors que vous pouvez nous
l'annoncer si elle est faisable est-ce
que vous en aurez plus l'oracle de
verser le président de la république a
été très clair présence d'un public a
dit nous verrons en fonction des marges
qui seront devant nous quels seront les
possibilités pour avoir des baisses
d'impôts l'année prochaine nous le
souhaitons ces baisses d'impôt nous
avons commencé vous avez eu la
gentillesse l'objectivité de rappeler
qu'effectivement ça a été le cas en 2015
les prélèvements obligatoires dire
l'ensemble de ce que le l'état en tous
cas les collectivités publiques donnant
comme contribution ont baissé entre
heureusement les champions d'europe 1
oui m'enfin sont blessés auraient
société champion d'europe sur un certain
nombre de prestations que l'on fournit à
nos concitoyens on peut parler de la
santé on peut parler de la retraite etc
mais c'est mais la peau l'impôt sur le
revenu puisque vous en parlez c'est le
moment des déclarations d'impôts les
français effectivement sont concernés
sur l'impôt qu'il est et touche le plus
mais c'est pas c'est d'ailleurs le plus
important pour le pays nous sommes
maintenant fin du mois de mai d'une
année budgétaire
aujourd'hui comment voulez-vous alors
même que les français sont seulement en
train de remplir leur déclaration
d'impôts que je sache que nous sachions
à bercy avec nos équipes
combien les recettes de l'état vont être
pour cette année en cours une année qui
est à peine commencée les recettes de
tva sur un précédent d'annoncer des
baisses d'impôts donc parce que nous
avions deux vous aurez tous heureux mais
non je suis prudent on peut pas entendre
mais vous vous étiez prévisions de
croissance confirmée par la loi
l'année dernière à la même époque on ne
lisait votre chrono de prévisions de
croissance ne sera pas atteinte il va
vous manquer 10 milliards de recettes
à la fin de l'année il a manqué 0
milliards de recettes elles ont été
conformes à nos prévisions les plus
optimistes
clairement indiquer clairement indiqué
nous en sommes s'expliquer avec lui mais
ça s'appelle mois entre autres avec le
premier ministre a clairement indiqué
que nous ferons le point fin du mois de
juin au début du mois de juillet lorsque
nous aurons affiner nos prévisions de
recettes pour cette année et qu'en
fonction effectivement des tendances qui
seront confirmées ou infirmées en
fonction de l'évolution de nos recettes
en fonction des taux d'intérêt en
fonction de la croissance qui sera
constaté aujourd'hui on connaît les
résultats du premier trimestre et encore
enfin le 14 juillet ce sera le 14
juillet le 13 ou au début du mois de
septembre la loi de finances sera
présenté au conseil des ministres
comme tous les ans à la fin du mois de
septembre mais il sera quand même le
dernier j'étais en général écoutez si
les marges apparaît se confirme et
peuvent se quantifier on verra sous
quelle forme
est ce que ça veut dire que les
différentes les nouvelles dépenses que
vous avez annoncé depuis janvier qui
sont intervenus comme comme un disait ce
sénateur très très très rapidement après
le vote de la loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
tellement importante que finalement la
fameuse redistribution dont parlait
françois hollande depuis un an ou deux
et déjà fait enfin une certaine manière
et que finalement ce n'est plus par
l'impôt que vous allez la cour suivant
poursuivre éventuellement mais ce que je
peux vous oubliez les uns les autres
c'est que des baisses d'impôts par
exemple pour les entreprises elles ont
déjà eu lieu là le 1er avril les
cotisations sociales tout le monde l'a
oublié des cotisations sociales des
employeurs ont baissé de pour pour près
de 4 milliards d'euros et le chef de
l'état libyen après les entreprises les
ménages
mais les minutes des mesures en faveur
des ménages on les a clairement rappelé
mais aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé 4
milliards effectivement de dépenses
supplémentaires
fallait-il ne pas l'appeler les mettre
en oeuvre ces mesures
fallait-il ne pas répondre à la crise
agricole avec près de 900 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires sur
des réductions de cotisations aux
agriculteurs fallait-il ne pas mettre en
oeuvre la prime à l embauche qui
arch bien le plan de formation qui va
nous coûter avec la prime à l'embauché
autour de 2 milliards dorothée n'a pas
en années les allées d'une parure comme
les laissons ce qui compte est que ces
mesures à porter la critique les points
à 10 a été bloqué pendant cinq ans cinq
ans c'est beaucoup d'efforts qui a été
demandé un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires même si nous avons pas
mais regardez la campagne auquel un
gorille des mesures demandées au
ministère ils ont supprimé des
fonctionnaires une baisse des effectifs
de 2 % c'est aussi la conséquence de
l'augmentation des points la ville c'est
pas nouveau ça ait pu dire nous nous
avons une stabilité globale nous avions
une stabilité globale de nos effectifs
durant les trois premières années de la
législature avec une augmentation des
enseignants une eau du nombre
d'enseignants avec une augmentation du
nombre de policiers avec une
augmentation du nombre de personnels à
la justice nous avons donc baisser nos
fonctionnaires dans un salon de services
à bercy dans service des finances
publiques nous supprimions environ 2000
postes tous les ans à la masse salariale
des fonctionnaires
il n'y a pas une baisse de la masse à
elle a augmenté de 0 9% réservé au
passage que ce chiffre le plus faible
depuis des années à l'augmenter
traditionnellement de 1 25%
elle n'a augmenté si j'ose dire que de 0
9%
donc il ya eu une maîtrise en tout cas
même c'est pas une baisse de la masse
salariale
parce qu'il ya quand même la promotion
chez les fonctionnaires qui conduisent
naturellement même si points à 10 est
gelée à une augmentation de revenus
donc ces 4 milliards c'est ce que nous
avions fait l'année dernière année
dernière en cours d'année on a vu des
mesures sur la sécurité on avait eu des
mesures non il ya une opposition de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
conteste ce chiffre et parle de plus
notre plutôt de 6 milliards sinon ça il
a reconnu que ses troupes et gt gt la
commission des finances il ajoute des
dépenses de 2016 à des dépenses de 2010
est en fait vous êtes coincé par le chef
de l'état il a annoncé qu'il y aurait
est ce que j'ai l'air de quoi écouter
l'état à partir ont ils annoncé courant
je suis chez moi c'est cette année selon
une mission et que face aux pressions
c'est de réduire les déficits il ya deux
moyens de réduire les déficits c'est
d'augmenter les recettes par des
augmentations d'impôts il n'en est pas
question
à rome sur une stratégie réduction des
impôts nous l'avons déjà fait et nous
continuerons à le faire mais si nous
n'arrivons pas à contenir les dépenses
de façon suffisante
on ne pourra pas réduire les impôts et
réduire le déficit en même temps mais
j'observe c'est très important qu'en
2015 c'est ce que nous avons fait en
2015 nous avons réduit le déficit public
et nous avons réduit et prélèvements
obligatoires donc les impôts
une question sur les pressions sur
google qui est soupçonné de fraude fit
fraude fiscale également en france il ya
une perquisition du siège parisien ce
matin du géant américain
on sait que ça fait suite à une plainte
de l'administration fiscale
est ce que le bras de fer se durcit avec
avec google par le biais de la justice
alors je vous remercie beaucoup de me
poser cette question le bras de fer il a
toujours été dur contrairement à ce qui
est dit parfois où ce que certains
peuvent penser et légitimement nous
sommes astreints
je suis astreint au secret fiscal je ne
peux pas aujourd'hui vous dire combien
les cas elle dans quel délai voyez quand
même on sait que google ait menacé le
redressement d'un milliard trois cents
millions c'est vous qui le dites ça
c'est moi qui vais vous qui le dis c'est
pas démenti on sait que c'est que je ne
peux pas vous démentir je vous donne un
exemple à 9,5 entreprises
multinationales l'année dernière en 2015
ont fait l'objet redressements fiscaux
et de pénalités pour 3,3 milliards
d'euros à cinq et à 5 seulement nous
avons redressé 3,3 milliards d'euros de
d'impôts et de pénalités
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce
gouvernement
et c'est pour le moins une nouveauté est
un gouvernement qui travaille sur les
questions de fiscalité qui poursuit à ce
nombre d'entreprises nous ne faisons pas
de publicité aujourd'hui c'est le
parquet national et financier mais vous
avez vous avez rappelé que c'était sur
la planche oui
sur la base des plaintes d'ailleurs de
la direction et la justice les
magistrats financiers sont invités dans
cet état mais vous recevez en tant que
ministre est ce que vous seriez prêt à
une transaction google non il n'ya pas
de transactions dans ce pays nous avons
été sollicité plusieurs fois et que ça
s'est passé en bretagne me vis à ses
patients de rentrée et vous avez vu
qu'elle a été le montant des retraites
c'est qu'elle espérait initialement
beaucoup moins que la somme sp d'entre
elles âgées leur local en charge en tout
cas c'est le fisc aujourd'hui qui a
notifié le redressement
si google souhaite google et d'autres
souhaitent aller au bout des procédures
ils iront au bout des procédures mais
nous ne ferons pas de transactions sur
ce type de situation
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'est ce que je
maintiens sur la situation financière
des collectivités territoriales les
dotations de l'état représentent un
quart des recettes des collectivités
territoriales ce car nous l'avons baissé
de 8%
oui 2.2 les dotations aux collectivités
oui pour ça représente pour le quart de
leurs recettes
une baisse significative 3,66 milliards
environ mais sa balle reste le reste des
recettes des collectivités territoriales
le recettes fiscales que ce soit les
impôts locaux que ce soit la cvae pardon
de dans ses mots sa technique
oui mais en face sont des impôts que
paye toutes les entreprises la
contribution foncière des entreprises
tous les incroyants mutation et droit
d'injonction dans sa volonté ont
augmenté sans variation des taux de
façon considérable pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les bases sont
révisés tous les ans pour certaines
d'entre elles et pour d'autres notamment
les dm tous les droits de mutation comme
vous l'évoquez mais nos questions
augmenter le marché immobilier s'est
décoincé et donc quand on regarde
l'ensemble de leurs recettes elles n'ont
pas baissé
elles ont augmenté de 1,9 70% pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
pris ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire
que les mesures que vous avez mis en
place et cette baisse des dotations pour
est-ce qu'il vous dise aujourd'hui c'est
une provocation on ne vous croit pas ce
que parce que ils sont été habitué à une
situation beaucoup plus confortable est
ce que vous croyez que c'est facile pour
l'état de réunir les ministres et de
leur demander des efforts de réduction
de leurs effectifs de leurs moyens et
qu'ils ont été de langues et 20
dictionnaires avançant je pense que
mentalement j'ai été du local je crois
connaître un peu cette situation j'étais
du régional
aussi il y a trois raisons pour
lesquelles l'investissement si je ne
conteste pas je lui ai dit d'ailleurs tu
m'écris est tempérée non il n'est pas en
péril il a baissé alors ils baissent
systématiquement lorsqu'il ya des
renouvellements électoraux ce qui était
le cas généralement une baisse de
l'ordre de 8%
il a baissé de l'ampl 11% c'est plus que
d'habitude c'est vrai plus que
d'habitude aussi parce que les équipes
pour quand même plus changer que
d'habitude notamment thème nantes
sur politique deuxième raison
l'incertitude sur un seul nombre de
textes qui sont venus à être mis en
oeuvre tardivement et nous avons au
gouvernement notre part de
responsabilité la fusion des régions a
mis du temps à se faire
la carte des intercommunalités qui vient
d'être arrêté au 31 mars a mis du temps
à se faire
ça veut dire que des collectivités des
communes des intercommunalités qui ne
savait pas dans quelle configuration se
retrouvait le lendemain avec quelles
compétences ont retardé vous le reste
aujourd'hui maintenant ça suffit vous
investissez non je le redis aujourd'hui
regardez les collectivités locales
encore un chiffre des pauses
traditionnellement trésor 30 milliards
d'euros en fin d'année l'année dernière
c'était 34 c'est à dire 4 milliards de
plus que nous avait déjà dit mais contre
tous contre tous les élus de france le
droit de gauche sont alors comment
expliquer ce phénomène inédit dans ce
vestiaire
d'abord je ne crois pas être seul un peu
plus de deux collègues y compris au
gouvernement qui partagent cette analyse
moi c'est une analyse que je donne mais
si vous voulez baisser la dépense
publique vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que nous étions les champions d'europe
de la dépense publique mais sait pas
quelle vaste et plus les dépenses des
collectivités territoriales sont
supérieures aux dépenses de l'état vous
faut l'avoir en tête ou à peu près en
tout cas équivalente
donc on peut pas imaginer baisser la
dépense publique
si on ne baisse pas la dépense des
collectivités territoriales et la moins
augmenté que d'habitude d'ailleurs c'est
un premier résultat
donc ce que je suis prêt à la
confrontation à la confrontation vous
êtes prêt à la confrontation qui revient
à ben écoute est vrai avec le chocolat
les élus je suis pas l'habitude de faire
vous allez y aller au congrès des maires
non parce que je suis pas un engagement
mais j y en a qui va y aller cette
raison de lacunes justement le mot ce
qu'il peut éviter la bronca du public
qui sera sur place mais qu'est ce qu'il
doit faire pour éviter cette branche
généralement quand on rend visite à
quelqu'un on arrive avec des fleurs
cadeaux à livron un cadeau mais je pense
que l'entente rené abric fera certain
nombre de d'annonce au congrès des
maires sur
la dgf la réforme de la dgf le montant
de la réduction d'un des chefs
les dotations versées par l'état il y
aura des annonces du chef de l'état donc
tu connais le diverses personnes
personne ne peut penser un seul instant
que le chef de l'état n'aura pas un
certain nombre de messages apportée aux
mères mais pas seulement mer des
messages des mesures
oui mais enfin ce n'est les maires ne se
contente pas de parole
monsieur fillon d'y faire travailler 39
heures mais il dit pas s'il paye 39 35
heures qu'il le dise lui dit aux gens
qui aujourd'hui vitré 35 heures je
mettrais 39 heures mais si c'est pour le
même salaire et le dit pas je sais pas
comment on va faire
autre élément alors c'est pas monsieur
fillon sarkozy choix qui court sans
parler de la baisse de l'impôt
oui enfin il propose aussi d'imposer aux
collectivités territoriales ne pas de ne
plus embaucher au moment du départ en
retraite
comment ils peuvent être sûrs d'eux et
mais comment il peut le faire la
constitution de notre pays donne la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des lois du
pays
je peux voir que vous êtes toujours
aujourd'hui tout le monde est vent
debout contre une baisse des dotations
qui l'est ce qui mettrait le pays laisse
encore augmenter les recettes de des
collectivités locales vous allez leur
dire que qu'il ne remplace pas leurs
fonctionnaires de façon autoritaire
ceci c'est une politique de gribouille
et cent mille fonctionnaires à bercy
nous sommes un émissaire qui supprimant
le plus emploi des moindres la par
exemple de la direction générale des
finances publiques deux mille 2000 et
c'est difficile je voulais vous montre
les lettres des maires des sénateurs des
députés
les républicains qui m'écrivent il ne
faut pas à tarbes ferme et à lagence
telle trésorerie ne faut pas à agen il
ne faut pas à bordeaux
regroupés fait quand elle promettait la
rupture il vous remettra lors que nous
faisons 2000 suppressions d'emplois à
bercy il vous en promettent cent mille
par an mais ceux ci étaient impossibles